auch im allerletzten bundesland klingeln
die wecker ab jetzt wieder früher denn
die sommerferien sind in ganz
deutschland vorbei und wir nutzen das
heute um mal genauer auf unser
schulsystem zu schauen und die frage zu
stellen ist das eigentlich zeitgemäß was
da so passiert in unseren klassenzimmern
darüber spreche ich gleich mit der
abiturientin und buchautorin jamila
tressel die kritisiert dass die welt
sich zwar sehr stark verändert die
schule aber nicht mich interessiert eure
meinung dazu
oder vielleicht habt ihr auch fragen zu
diesem thema dann postet sie mir gerne
hier unten in die kommentare
und wir beginnen jetzt mal mit einem
lehrer der dem schulunterricht ziemlich
schlechte noten geben würde und schule
so wie sie jetzt ist am liebsten
abschaffen würde schafft die schule ab
es ist eine drastische forderung der
langjährige lehrer und ehemalige
schulleiter oliver hauser hat darüber
ein radikales buch geschrieben
einst war er für sprecher der
klassischen schulbildung heute fordert
er eine fundamentale veränderung des
schulsystems
wir sind jetzt im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert das wissen verbreitet sich
ganz schnell neuem wir gehen mit neuen
medien um aber schule findet im grunde
stadt wie vor 30 40 50 jahren da hat
sich nicht viel geändert
die schüler sitzen in reihen gepfercht
vorne erzählt der lehrer was vielleicht
haben wir uns in der einen oder anderen
methode etwas verändert aber das
grundprinzip schule ist das gleiche
geblieben und das muss sich verändern
weg vom klassensystem mehr projektarbeit
freies lernen individuelles arbeiten und
gleitzeit so hauses vision schule müsse
den mut haben sich von fächern zu
trennen insgesamt weniger
unterrichtsstoff und vor allem keine
noten mehr
ich halte von noten überhaupt gar nichts
noten besprochenen in die falsche
richtung an noten machen unnötig druck
und sie sagen über unsere kinder
überhaupt nichts aus ja wir versuchen 30
kinder oder meinetwegen 1000 kinder an
einer schule in sechs ziffern zu packen
und glauben wir würden ihre
individualität damit gerecht werden
besonders hart geht hauschke mit seinen
kollegen ins gericht die meisten lehrer
seien empathie los und nicht an ihren
schülern als menschen interessiert
findet ein großteil der kollegen ist das
fach das wichtigste das sie studiert
haben
sie haben auch viel zeit rein investiert
kann man ein stück weit vielleicht auch
verstehen das zweitwichtigste ist das
curriculum was ihnen gestellt wird was
sie durchziehen müssen ja und die kinder
sind eben oder das mittel dazu haus
gehabt selber kinder sechs davon im
schulpflichtigen alter
sein fazit das derzeitige system
vermittler den schülern kein wissen
sondern frust und dem motivation und
damit seien die öffentlich staatlichen
schulen verschwendete lebenszeit der
kinder
ja ein drastisches fazit und auch
drastische forderungen über die wir
sprechen wollen und war mit jamil
adresse dies engagiert in der initiative
schule im aufbruch fordert dass schule
reformiert wird und ist mir als über
skype zugeschaltet guten abend rasse
sehr guten abend adresse wenn bei ihnen
früher der wecker geklingelt hat haben
sie sich darauf die schule gefreut oder
haben sie gedacht na ja wieder ein tag
verschwendete lebenszeit
das kam total auf die schule handeln
denn ich habe auch sehr unterschiedliche
schulerfahrung so wie er ausgeht dass
auch geschrieben hat war ich auf dem
klassischen gymnasium ein jahr lang und
habe auch den druck die konkurrenz und
die die motivation erlebt da habe ich
mich nicht gefreut wenn mein wecker
geklingelt hat da hatte ich eher angst
zu stelle wird werde ich jeden morgen
und auch abends beim einschlafen aber in
den letzten jahren bin ich eben auch
tatsächlich auf eine schule gegangen wo
ich gerne hingegangen bin wo ich das
gefühl hatte ich lebte als mensch
wahrgenommen ich werde dort gefördert
und da kann ich etwas fürs leben
mitnehmen und lernen natürlich nicht
jeden tag aber immer öfter so dass ich
nicht im großen und ganzen das auch eine
gute seite hat und mich darauf gefreut
habe ihn nicht studieren zu können
jetzt fordert ja heraus können komplett
reform des schulsystems im prinzip was
muss sich denn auf ihrer sicht daran
ändern
jetzt ist uns gerade die verbindung
abgebrochen
ich hör mal ganz kurz in die regie ob
sich da noch mal was tut ob wir das
nochmal aufbauen können
sie ist wieder da höre ich gerade ich
sehe sie aber noch nicht ja da das wird
super wunderbar noch mal die frage was
müsste sich denn aus ihrer sicht anderen
am schulsystem als müssten sich auch
radikal ganz viel ändern und hat keine
kleine reformation passieren sondern
eigentlich eine große transformation der
bildung allein einstellung und haltung
was den schülern vermittelt wird stehen
klotener im vordergrund der ganze druck
die konkurrenten dass ich denke das ist
absolut nicht mehr zeitgemäß und ich
denke dass ich einfach grundsätzlich das
ganze system ändern müsste um auch zu
gewährleisten dass schüler für die
zukunft fit gemacht werden
lust haben die großen probleme anzugehen
die nicht auszusetzen auszusitzen
das ist heute ganz gut was hier das
heißt letztendlich brauchen
durch strukturen aber vor allem der neue
grundhaltung medienschule herangehen und
wie wir kinder sozusagen lehrern
unterrichten unterziehen sie kommen
schon die ersten kommentare rein einer
zum beispiel von melanie und zwar bei
facebook die sagt hört doch mal auf mit
den permanenten reformen und co
seit jahren sind die schüler und schulen
die versuchskaninchen
das ist jetzt quasi in der kritik es
gibt aber auch viele die sagen ja es
muss sich unbedingt was tun
hier in der schule und die haben ja
jetzt schon quasi gerade angesprochen
dass wie also wie unterrichtet wird
hat sich da nicht auch viel getan in der
vergangenheit also zum beispiel mehr
gruppenarbeit es gibt sicherlich weniger
strafen als vielleicht vor 40 jahren
und irgendwie auch weniger
frontalunterricht oder ja es hat sich
sicherlich auch schon einiges getan also
glücklicherweise das kann ja auch nicht
sein dass ich die ganze welt nicht
verändert habe ich mir überhaupt nicht
mitglied auch stichwort digitalisierung
sagen immobilie ja wir machen doch schon
viel wir haben jetzt auch tablets das
ist aber keine andere grundhaltung die
dadurch gelegt wird als schul kultur und
ich denke auch es gibt weniger strafen
mehr gruppenarbeit alles schön was sind
immer so kleine verbesserungen die man
gemacht werden wenn eben ein gutes
probleme auftritt aber es ist wie gesagt
grundsätzlich eine sehr gute struktur
lehrer steht vorne schüler hören zu
werden meistens frontal bescheid ist
noch nicht so viel geändert worden
gerade im klassischen sinne aber es gibt
natürlich auch schon viele freie schule
und wie viele reformschulen sage ich mal
die ja wie es anders machen und
vielleicht dann auch versuchskaninchen
sind aber die ganze erde ist ja auch
irgendwie
man muss ja auch anfangen dinge anders
zu machen und dinge auszuprobieren denn
wenn man es nicht wagt diesen mut nicht
aufbringt auch etwas anders zu machen
auch wenn es dann vielleicht mal nicht
das gewünschte ergebnis erzielt
ich denke aus meiner sicht ist alles was
neues an kreativen ideen auch was von
schule schülern in einem prozess kommt
wie man schon verändern kann besser als
das alte system und die fordern ja nicht
nur das ich
etwas am wie verändert sondern auch
etwas daran verändert was unterrichtet
wird also welche fächer zum beispiel
welche fächer würden sie dann zum
beispiel abschaffen und welche würden
sie neu einführen
also ich bin ein großer verfechter der
das grundlagenwissen ich denke es ist
sinnvoll dass man gewisse grundlagen
lernt in der schule aber ich glaube
nicht dass wieder aktuell nachhaltig tun
in dem maße das wirklich gebraucht wird
an wissen von dem wir 40 prozent nach
und zwei jahren nach immer wieder
vergessen haben und auch nie wieder
brauchen werden dass man diesen lehrplan
radikal kürzen könnte sagen die und die
grundlagen lesen rechtschreibung prozent
rechnen sodass du braucht man kann ich
das versteht doch jeder das sieht auch
jeder ein
und was darüber hinaus geht dass man da
viel mehr wahlmöglichkeiten lässt den
schülern wo sie sich dann auch vertiefen
wollen was sie interessiert was sie
begeistert wo sie auch lust haben sich
gegenseitig bereichern und beizubringen
das ist die eine seite inhaltlich und
dann finde ich das noch ganz wieder auch
in der schule fehlt an
persönlichkeitsbildung an wie komme ich
was mache ich wenn ich an meine grenzen
komme wie passe ich auf mich selbst auch
wie gehe ich mit meinem persönlichen
ressourcen um wie schaffe ich es ist
beste aus mir rauszuholen was sind
überhaupt meine stärken liegen
vielleicht meine sprechen wo möchte ich
mich noch verbessern
all diese dinge darauf wird momentan in
der schule alles noch viel zu wenig die
könnte dann so ein schulfach heißen oder
aussehen weil das sind ja jetzt schon
sehr grundlegende themen also der schule
wo ich jetzt die letzten jahre war
dynamisch und jede neue märkte und auch
tatsächlich neue fächer entwickelt um
diese dinge zu lernen zum beispiel
einfach verantwortung ganz wichtiges
thema denn eigentlich in der zukunft wir
müssen andere lernt waren für uns
übernehmen unseren planeten klar aber
auch im freien für die familie
befreundete uns selbst und da haben wir
tatsächlich einfach das heißt
verantwortung wo wir wirklich einmal die
woche ins gemeinwesen gehen und uns da
engagieren wirklich so wollen sich die
kinder auch an stark engagieren und tun
sie auch fehle und wenn sie dafür dann
macht das immerhin schon beginnt und in
demonstrieren gehen
wir haben das sowieso im schulalltag
integriert dass wir als beispiel und
auch das nur flüchtlingsheim
in altenheimen oder ökologisch bäume
pflanzen was auch immer du denkst du
gebraucht werden kannst und ich auch ex
schüler selbst würde sein leben kannst
eine wichtige erfahrung denke ich das
wird da beigebracht verantwortung zu
übernehmen das ist etwas das kannst du
nicht aus dem schulbuch wir haben es
musste einfach erleben und das ein
tolles gefühl hier kommt auch einen ganz
heißen der kommentar zu dem thema und
zwar von gerd bei facebook der sagt auch
was zum thema schulfächer und zwar meint
er dass es wichtig ist dass die
wichtigen fächer was auch immer er ganz
genau damit meint nicht abgewählt werden
dürften das sei ein verbrechen an den
schülern
wer das abitur erlangt hat sollte auch
über ein gewisses allgemeinwissen
verfügen meine tochter hat zwar
promoviert kennt aber nicht die sieben
kontinente unfassbar
also hier gibt sich auch in den
kommentaren viel gedanken gemacht über
die systeme dass das ist absolut ein wie
gesagt ich bin auch der meinung dass
grundlagen und ein bisschen welt bildung
nicht schadet und wie auch nicht fehlen
darf man muss ja auch was verstehen ich
glaube was die große aufgabe von
schülern von schule ist ja auch die
schüler zu mündigen bürgern auch
heranzuziehen und dazu gehört nun mal
dass man ein gewisses wissen hat über
die welt und sich seine eigenen gedanken
macht und das kann man ja gar nicht
immer nicht die entsprechenden
grundlagen um die welt überhaupt
ansatzweise zu verstehen also das ist
auf jeden fall wichtig und klar die
wichtigen welcher darüber kann man sich
streiten was das ist ob damit jetzt ihr
habt euch an mathe deutsch englisch
gemeint sind oder eben auch alles was
sonst noch gibt an schule ich würde da
gar nicht differenzieren zwischen das
ist richtig und wichtig und das ist
nebensächlich anzuschauen ok alles
sollte seinen platz irgendwann kann über
das an lehrern dass sie schüler da
irgendwie kreativität leben kennen mit
dem er in der sie geboren sind und
sprach dabei nicht verlieren frau
tressel wir sprechen gleich noch weiter
wir gucken jetzt aber in unserem
nächsten beitrag noch mal auf einen
anderen lehrer wir haben nämlich noch
mit einem anderen lehrer gesprochen mit
kai schmidt der ist mathe lehrer und
schulleiter aus niedersachsen und hat
außerdem einen youtube kanal wo er lernt
tipps gibt und er findet das schulsystem
so wie es jetzt gerade ist eigentlich
ziemlich gut
[Musik]
ich finde es gibt dinge über die müssen
wir reden im schulsystem keine frage
aber im großen und ganzen denke ich
laufen viele dinge auch wirklich richtig
gut bei unserem schulsystem
[Musik]
ich bin ein großer fan vom notensystem
ich glaube eine direkte rückmeldung über
leistungen und trinkfest und sind ganz
ganz wichtig und ich bin auch der
meinung in den letzten jahren sind wir
zunehmend dazu gekommen dass wir so
schlecht leistungen irgendwie so klein
reden ich finde das gar nicht stimmt
warum darf man jungen menschen nicht
sagen hey das hast du nicht gut gemacht
das musst du möglicherweise auch mal
machen
[Musik]
also ich glaube das muss man wirklich
absolut individuell betrachten also
natürlich ist unser job das ist muss zu
vermitteln was in unseren schulen
eigenen arbeitsplänen dann gibt in kuba
steht natürlich das ist unser aber ich
sag mal als selbstverständlich kümmern
wir uns unsere schüler und wenn es geben
aktuell belange geht dann kümmern wir
uns zuerst um die schüler die schule
bereit bestimmt nicht auf alles im leben
vor
aber das ziel aus meiner sicht auch
nicht wenn man in der schule lernt wie
man sich einem problem stellt wie man
daher angeht ich glaube dann kann man
auch die aufgaben die nachrichten
gekommen meist und wir sprechen darüber
weiter mit camille adresse presse
kai schmidt bezeichnet sich jetzt selber
als fan des aktuellen notensystems wo
würden sie sich denn da einordnen
ich bin definitiv kein fan und auch kein
verfechter vermuten nicht glaube dass
noten überholt sind es wurde
vorhin auch angesprochen ich glaube
nicht dass man die folgen kinder dieser
welt die alle so unterschiedlich sind in
sechs kategorien verorten kann man sagt
du bist hier nicht ausreichend und
ungenügend oder du bist sehr gut was das
hat mir persönlich immer nicht so viel
gegeben ich habe mich in meiner arbeit
nicht wertgeschätzt gefühlt weil ich
nicht das gefühl hatte dass die noten
das widerspiegeln was ich eigentlich
gemeistert habe oder eben auch nicht
geleistet hat was wo ich aber zustimmen
ist dass man auch als kind gerne eine
rückmeldung habe
über die bewertung des hand da steckt
ist wer drin ich bin mir einfach eine
wertschätzung ist wichtig aber aber
natürlich auch ein konstruktives
friedberg mit dem ich aber etwas
anfangen kann und das ist bei der not
ich finde ich auch nicht der fall das
und ich weiß was konkret weil ich den
nicht verbessern sondern lieber wie auch
gesagt wurde dass man mir sagt ja hier
und da passt einfach noch schwachstellen
guck doch dahin macht noch nie es noch
etwas weiter das ist so konkret wie
möglich ist damit ihr auch wirklich eine
chance hatte mich zu verbessern und das
nicht nur kramer mich einzustufen und zu
bewerten damit jemand es leichter hat
unter auswahlkriterien zu spucken
wer denn jetzt wo arbeitet und wie gut
ist er das wirklich nur einfach nicht
ausgedrückt interessanterweise kommen
hier auch zum thema noten von euch
relativ viele kommentare einer unter
anderem hier bei twitter von saft
automaten er sagt ohne noten hätte ich
noch weniger als wenig für die schule
gemacht oder hängt man schreibt aber
noten komplett zu canceln ist meiner
ansicht nach unsinn entweder ein
alternatives bewertungssystem da könnte
man sicherlich drüber diskutieren und
jetzt nochmal um auf den vorherigen
kommentar bezug zu nehmen
es ist ja schon so wenn man jetzt keine
noten bekommt hat man ja im prinzip auch
also man kann es als druck bezeichnet
man kann auch sagen auch keine
motivation fleißig zu sein vokabeln zu
lernen war fährt auch nicht der größte
spaß auf der welt ist wo ist eigentlich
schon am ort zu halten dass auch an
unseren schulen und gesellschaft das ist
dass es nicht geschafft wird eine
motivation herzustellen ohne die kinder
im gewissen druck auf das so sagt sind
ich denke nämlich wenn kinder auf die
welt kommen und da sieht man auch an
kindergärten und ich selbst an meinen
kleinen geschwistern früher und bei
einem kindern die ich gerne bietet die
lernen unglaublich gerne die sind
unglaublich neugierig wollen alles
wissen fragen der löcher in den bauch
spricht die habe neugierde und hamm
intrinsische motivation zu lernen und
wie schafft es die schule diese
motivation zu deckeln und verbrechen
dafür zu sorgen dass wenig den mit ihm
sagen ohne noten will ich gar nicht mehr
lernen die noten sind meine motivation
meine belohnung oder das warum warum ich
mich auch nur ansatzweise an strenge
damit ich mich beweisen kann es ist
natürlich auch eine motivation aber die
ist eben sehr extrem motiviert und das
wenden sich an sich sehr schade weil ich
weiß von mir und auch vielen werden
noten wenn meine schule damit dadurch
bin ich super klar gekommen deshalb
vieles liegt also ich bin gelassen hat
nicht mehr getan habe aber ich hatte
eine ganz andere motivation dahinter und
ich wusste warum ich jetzt tue ich und
ich habe eben nicht mehr knothe gelernt
sondern für mich und mein leben und das
müsste eigentlich die motivation
hingehen und wenn das jedem schüler
bewusst wird und dafür wird die schule
mit waren möglich sein dann ist es eben
auch möglich über ein alternatives
bewertungssystem oder feedback system zu
reden und das einzelstück und ohne dass
da die motivation verloren geht also
verstehe ich sie im prinzip richtig die
werden dafür eigentlich noten komplett
in der gesamten schullaufbahn bis hin
zum abitur eigentlich abzuschaffen
ich glaube einfach dass noten nicht
unbedingt zumindest bis argumentiert
wird als bewertungssystem gar nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind dass schüler
auch lernen wenn sie nicht ständig das
wir bewertet oder kontrolliert werden
aber ich sehe natürlich auch was
dahinter steckt an noten das macht es
einfach auch für lehrer vielleicht
einfacher dinge zu bewerten das macht
später die auswahl trifft leichter
universität zu sagen wir machen bei 1,9
schluss oder oder einfach nur zum
beispiel wenn in der halle zum beispiel
wären jetzt ein arbeitgeber sagt ich
suche ein buchhalter der muss irgendwie
gut in mathe sein
da kann er einfach aufs zeugnis schauen
und kann sagen ach guck mal der bewerber
der passt doch zu uns das wird dann ja
komplett wegfallen oder sein also ich
rede hier nicht davon kann überhaupt
keine einschätzung eines schülers
ich finde es total wichtig dass er auch
in seinen stärken und schwächen
wahrgenommen wird und das dann auch
geschrieben wird dass ein arbeitgeber
immer die chance hat zu gucken wer bist
du denn eigentlich oder im idealfall
vielleicht selbst dazu befragt und der
das irgendwie beweisen kann aber ich
glaube nicht dass das und noten und
endet am besten rüberkommt ganz im
gegenteil minuten können auf der
subjektiven sein
es gibt also meiner schulzeit ich hab
wirklich gute noten gehabt aber es ich
habe mich nicht unbedingt als so viel
besser in manchen dingen empfunden als
an anderen schulen anderer schüler die
wesentlich schlechtere noten hatten die
haben dann entweder sind sie mit dem
lehrer nicht gut klar gekommen oder
haben sich mündlich nicht so engagiert
waren aber trotzdem super steht in mathe
den jeder klassenarbeiten 1 aber
mündlich eben nicht und deswegen war es
dann insgesamt nur drei dann hier also
das heißt ich kenne das nur vielleicht
so aussagekräftig sind wie immer so sie
werden immer objektiv dargestellt sind
sie aber im grunde nicht
letztlich auch nicht so sehr aus also
noten wert zb ein punkt an denen wie
schrauben würden das habe ich jetzt
mitbekommen was wenn denn sonst noch so
stellschrauben wenn sie jetzt sagen
könnten sie können ein paar sachen im
schulsystem jetzt ändern verbessern was
würden sie angehen
also wenn ich wirklich ein zauberstab
stehen könnte dann wäre sein erster
linie die grundhaltung und einstellung
wieder wirklich den schüler in den
mittelpunkt zu rücken zu sagen was
wollen wir eigentlich was ist wenn wir
unser ziel das möchten wählen in welcher
gesellschaft möchten wir leben diese
frage zu stellen und dann darauf zu
schauen gut gehe und die gesellschaft
können wir uns vorstellen
und wie müssen jetzt unsere schulen
aussehen
das wäre tatsächlich auch dahin kommen
dass wir friedlich zusammenleben können
und gegen respektieren und unterstützen
statt immer gegeneinander zu arbeiten zu
sagen wenn wir uns gegenseitig helfen
und eine tolle gesellschaft aufbauen und
dafür würde ich brauche es in der schule
ganz fundamental neue strukturen neue
fächer meinetwegen auch dieses fläche
konzept das wirklich so eng geschnürt
ist auch zu lockern
dass man wirklich die chance hat auch
als viele sich deutlich zu erleben sich
selbst kennen zu lernen zu lernen wo und
wann und wie lerne ich am besten wie
kann ich mich am besten einbringen was
in meine stärken meine schwächen spricht
diese die persönlichkeitsentwicklung der
eigentlich auch im vordergrund stehen
sollte wirklich auch mal in den
vordergrund zu rücken und zu sagen wir
versuchen hier wirklich eine
individuelle förderung und forderung
aber auch den schülern familie hat
russell war das vielen dank für das
gespräch und dass sie sich die zeit
heute für uns genommen haben und ich
bedanke mich natürlich auch ganz
herzlich bei euch für die vielen
kommentare aber auch für die vielen
fragen die hier reingekommen sind und
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten live stream auch wieder dabei
seit der findet am donnerstag statt um
20 uhr 30 wie gewohnt bis dahin tschüss
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann findet ihr vielleicht
auch den hier interessant da ging es um
die vorteile einer berufsausbildung oder
der hier das dann fällt auch ganz
spannend haben wir mit luisa neubauer
über frederic for future gesprochen oder
ihr klickt einfach mal hier
da könnt ihr den neuen zdf- heute-
youtube-kanal abonnieren
[Musik]